Plainfield New Jersey a middle-class
city with a strong sense of community
and smack in the middle of town is a
soul food restaurant named blackberries
run by a one successful caterer named
Shelley Withers
[Music]
fantastic I
had tremendous following it just seemed
natural that I would move on to open a
restaurant oh why you're welcome and
with her mother Mary investing her
entire retirement fund into the
restaurant Shelley's Dream came true
daddy put the check in the bank this
afternoon oh okay
I think it's a parent's responsibility
to be supportive of their children I am
so happy with the way the restaurant
turned down the decor is phenomenal I'm
not sure if I understood and
blackberries has the best soul food in
town no doubt fried collard greens is my
favorite I don't know what I'm doing
wrong the shrimp was firm that's because
I forgot them on the stove
perfect location
perfect food but where are my customers
the problem is Shelly is in denial she
thinks that the decor is amazing and the
food tastes spectacular I like it but
the food is suffering the customers are
suffering and the restaurant is
suffering the macaroni actually
believes that all of her food is better
than any chef out there two done
two done is perfect she feels this is
the way I want it it tastes good it
doesn't matter what someone else thinks
about it
it'd be in my restaurant I'm gonna have
it my way I don't want the food to touch
I say it every day and you're doing it
to me anyway right it don't make sense
to me Shelly is a super controlled freak
to the 110th power I need you to not
these [ __ ]
and 16 people doing their own system
cable five right there in the front
where is it please
got no food down here you think she
knows what she's doing when she actually
has no idea what she's doing tell me
what I can do to help I don't I don't
understand what's going on and that
brings a lot of chaos here let me see
that play
[Music]
he's helping the restaurant to fail even
more
so bad I'm two hundred thousand dollars
in debt I'm barely holding on here I got
fourteen dollars to my name bro like I
tell Shelly it's just not only her at
this restaurant spells because I have
sacrificed a lot to make sure that the
doors didn't close
I believe in the power of prayer I think
Chef Ramsey is the answer to her prayers
[Music]
what an amazing fuzzy little town great
location for a restaurant
okay
hello
welcome thank you for having to be here
wow look at this place somebody having a
party
[Music]
no no party was just having um lunch
okay great let me see you okay so
it's a big boy there who's that
assistant James James what's your job
general manager
stealth pants with a baby face like that
you can't even management get out of
here you look about 18 how old are you
I'm 30 years old wow amazing aging well
and this is Mom Mary Mother Mary yes sir
you look great nice thing what do you do
the cakes the pies the desserts really
she's our Baker okay grace
is here
I don't want to be sweating all over him
can I kiss him can I give him a kiss and
thank him for coming or what you're
about to be all around
hey how are you buddy how are you doing
good to see you're running around
you I have to be somebody's got to get
it done about three years who designed
this place I feel like Donna Summer's
gonna come through the door that would
be Michelle I think that would be me oh
I absolutely love the decor and dance
party that's me wow excuse me
guys I would ask my fiance if I could
kiss you she don't say he's a manager
the woman yeah oh come on sexy right you
get arrested for cradle snatching Hey
general manager come here get that beard
over here you didn't tell me that you're
dating the owner
excuse me
amazing and was it Love at First Bite
yeah wow way too much
oh man he's a little younger than I am
but he's my sexy chocolate let me sit
down have a quick look through the menu
start ordering thank you thank you for
coming Gordon
[Music]
I think I'm gonna say as much as I can
okay uh right let's go for uh collard
greens that's smothered pork chop sounds
delicious let's go for some mac and
cheese as well please okay the chitlins
and desserts how's the red velvet cake
delicious okay great very well I think
I'm starving we're gonna put your order
in excellent all right guys we have our
order for Chef all right let's do it I
really think that Chef Ramsay is going
to say that the food is phenomenal with
the pork chop with some math this is not
hot that's my favorite
foreign
oh Jesus
[Music]
what happened was it the fried chicken
or the cornbread what what Chipmunks
What happens I have no idea I've never
seen that before
oh [ __ ] oh my god did somebody head but
the wall it was shocking to find that it
was a hole in the wall with a record on
it I was just like oh my God like what
the hell is that doing there I've heard
about broken records but Jesus Christ
okay let's get out of here quick
I'm afraid to touch any other records
[Music]
all right here you go oh
Charlie is delusional about how fabulous
her food is I hate the macaroni and
cheese just looks like crap on a plate
this is pork chop this mother pork chop
thank you
just a little shot on my plate
[Music]
it's dry
[Music]
isn't there
how's your pork chop the pork chop is
dry the mac and cheese is way overcooked
and very mushy you think of soul food
restaurant would Pride itself on cooking
mac and cheese but now it's just all
is that heated in the microwave no I
think they just put it in the oven to
warm for our lunch service
thank you
oh he's saying that the macaroni and
cheese is dry and overcooked
he asked me have we warmed it in the
microwave I told him no it just came out
of the oven they may have put it in the
microwave for a minute
only for a minute though everything is
cooked to Perfection there is nothing on
that menu that is not perfect
okay here we go I'm taking over now five
collard greens move it to the middle put
an orange chip in the middle that's it
how can you actually see it as a social
restaurant are the collard greens are
not tasting like collard greens this is
this like pepper soil you know you can't
have food tasting like that tell Chef I
said to taste those collard greens
they're perfect
there you go chefs collard greens wow
okay great thank you very much indeed
wow
blindness his name is just fried and
soggy and limp
James
what do you think you gotta eat it all
together if you eat it all together it's
just well I did eat it all together it
still stayed Bland thank you
oh my God what is he saying about our
stuff now little blind
oh my God collard greens it's great he's
crazy where's the chitlins at it's in
the microwave they're delicious
and we get one out of three we might be
all right
and this is the chitlins and okra okay
let's
laughs
I mean I know titlets are being testing
but should they really stink
before I do taste them I'd like to pray
to God before I pray that in my mouth
in Jesus
Jesus you are prayed over we guarantee
you that you are not about to succumb to
those chitlins Hallelujah
you'll be fine
I just had to pray over Chef before he
ate the chitlins what the [ __ ]
there's no crazy Gonna Save Me on this
one oh my God
[Music]
check its shipments I need the toilet
excuse me I knew they'd come out quicker
than it went in
Severance is a mess
[Music]
oh it's chairs
that would be crap
are you kidding me oh my god oh they
stink oh
shall it be taking it lightly and not
seriously at all is he in the children's
bathroom I'm not sure but I guess the
prayer didn't work
oh dear dear you're not used to that
soul food huh
thank you
I want to see what's going on oh Jesus
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
wow that is delicious finally it's a
good [ __ ] food
wow how do you like this yeah it's
delicious wow
there's a way to the end I've been saved
by Mother Mary I've got the red velvet
that Mommy makes is gonna be beautiful
right because Mommy made it I'm gonna
punch him in the face
just show me into the kitchen please
thank you I sure will yep the chef is on
his way back I've scared I would I went
I'm scared to bring him here Shelly
doesn't listen but remember she gets
back there in the kitchen we'll see if
she even opens up to any suggestions or
not Hi how are you nice to meet you good
to see you soon pleasure
um this is
nice to meet you likewise good to see
you buddy uh so I just had an
embarrassing lunch
let's start from the top
pork chop dry Bland no seasoning and the
macaroni cheese was an embarrassment
fried collard greens there's no
seasoning everything's just fried so
just tasting the oil and horrible
the chitlins but the smell of them
almost made me want to gag
I absolutely do not believe that there's
that much wrong with my food who is the
head chef here I am show me tonight okay
well you think you are the head chef all
right
as Shelly and the staff prepare for
dinner service I thought it was good you
know to my stand
Chef Ramsay returns and is greeted by an
unexpected guest
[Music]
oof what is that let's see hell
damn
oh my god wow
it's just 10 minutes before the doors to
blackberries open and Chef Ramsay is
greeted by something unexpected bloody
hell
[Music]
that have you got a pin yes yeah it
moves just by the front door
it's by the door no we just had the
Exterminator you paid for the
Exterminator yeah get your money back
okay that's not funny I've got an
incinerator
outside can you take that no as a
general manager do something with it
the mouse
it was in the entrance as I walked in on
the left hand side
we always have the Exterminator once a
month of our prevention are you serious
be careful of mice
please show me where you found that at
hey it's at the front door oh well
where's the front door in your mind
I can't believe that
I came in the door walked in there saw
him and bang right there right here do
you have it on from are you kidding me
what you thought I brought it in out of
my pocket yeah I think you did are you
are you are you [ __ ] dreaming
I arrived the mouse was there never
never heard never it was no no never no
mouse right here right okay
so we have the Exterminator last week
they come on regular occasions yes we
have an issue with mice that's why you
have an exterminator we don't have an
issue with most exterminator comes in
okay let's let's you know I do a little
investigation let's go
Dwayne when's the last time you spotted
a mouse in here
I've never seen one you've never seen
one good
except that one that was under the steam
table that was bad a few months back
almost a year back
he found a mouse in the front door
I'd never been so embarrassed and
humiliated in my life
this is ridiculous really ridiculous
and sad
I never seen a mushrooms
perhaps you planted that mouth
and you were suggesting
that I brought it in I was like hmm I
put it together like
just for TV's sake maybe I wish you
would talk a little bit of sense [ __ ]
the TV plus your money where your mouth
is in front of your staff I want a
meeting upstairs with you and everybody
now
pulling mice out of his pockets and
stuff yeah
everybody keep bullshitting me my mouth
it's mice infested all over this place
it can happen it can happen
foreign
this is very very important
so
[Music]
I was telling him like almost like that
[Music]
so just look at James for me two seconds
I walked in the front door a mouse the
mouse that you planted I know they told
me but it's okay no it's not okay
it's got nothing to do with TV nothing
to do with your business in the [ __ ] I
am not gonna stand there and even
attempt to take that crap from you you
can take your restaurant and stick it I
am gone I'm out of it
you out of here I'm out of here excuse
me go see you later shut it down
it's over
after discovering a mouse in the
restaurant do you have it on phone and
being accused of planting it the mouse
that you planted I know Chef Ramsay has
had enough take your restaurant and
stick it I am gone
you out of here I'm out of here excuse
me go see you later shut it down let's
go it's over
it is not over
please shut up I mean it's ridiculous
it's ridiculous
I have worked tremendously trying to
support my child and I don't understand
you know it's I I don't understand
what's happening today honest to God I
don't
what I said as far as you doing
something like that I don't want to
defame your character but it just was
I'm lost for words that that happened
and it just it just like
shocked me and I apologize
that's the most sensible thing I've
heard you say since I've been here
thank you the combination of mother
Mary's plea and an apology by James are
enough to keep Chef Ramsay at
blackberries welcome to blackberries at
least for now yes sir this evening will
be Tina should be right with you
okay
and I'm going to get a macaroni and
cheese all right ladies let me put this
orders in first a lot of shrimp and
grits would probably be a shrimp and
grit knife
[Music]
got a free burner walk there is that a
pizza oven yeah yeah that's my pizza
oven and the wok I love it cheers show
you how can you cook soul food in a wok
IES soul food supposed to be cooked
slowly cooked with love and soul not in
a wok
Shelly's cooking green beans in a wok
cooking rice in a wok cabbage in a wok
we're not a Chinese soul food restaurant
we don't need a wok okay that's the
first of me a Southern food restaurants
with a Chinese wok and a pizza oven and
you have an oven that doesn't work right
there tell me what's working apart from
you
we haven't had correct broken ovens we
don't have to correct stoves the correct
fryers grills you know how can we
produce really great food if we don't
have really great ovens how did you
manage to fry everything in one fry like
that very hard a lot of prayer after
discovering unusual and dysfunctional
equipment in this soul food restaurant
Chef Ramsay turns his attention to
Shelley and how she runs her kitchen
Fried Chicken please how many weight
Meats do you need Fried Chicken but I'm
gonna call the artists
let's get one thing straight okay can
you please work on ticket one we are are
we I mean I don't understand
Shelly has no concept of what it means
to actually run a proper functional
kitchen washer one ticket at a time I
need you to do it that's what I'm doing
okay just one just do one that's what
that's how I do one just make it and
send it that's it make it and send it
unbelievable and where's the controller
check the system what what system are we
following here it's like there's no
system I mean this is a joke you try to
get one and she wants to argue you down
you know she needs to argue down and
make it seem like you're the one that's
wrong or it can't be running like that
but it's not making sense
I want you guys off the line just go
watch out just back up it's getting
ridiculous already it's been an hour and
a half but you just kind of want to get
up and move how long are you waiting
quite close an hour an hour
foreign
dysfunctional
simply one person controlling it I
have Shelly thinks she knows what she's
doing when she actually has no idea what
she's doing we need a miracle a prayer
hands on bending knees because this is
going to the shits here we go Fried
Chicken despite the ongoing chaos in the
kitchen dishes somehow make their way to
the dining room
and that's the result
you wait 90 minutes and this is what
you're lucky to get
[Music]
crazy there
that's crazy
and there's a war zone always ah always
welcome to Blackberry what's up random
let's see how what a welcoming
[Music]
coming up is her way or the highway when
the staff tries to get through to
Shelley I have been open-minded she goes
from the defensive to the offensive calm
down I want you to leave tell me to go I
know and then a dinner service
Blackberry spirals out of control
Chef Ramsay wondering if this restaurant
can be saved now you walk away bye
goodbye goodbye
it's day two at blackberries and Chef
Ramsay knows that before he can
Implement changes he has to focus on how
this restaurant is run and so he starts
the day with a staff meeting I want to
go round now to identify things that you
know that are wrong with the business
and things that you'd like to change in
the business
I think one thing is I've known Shelley
we kind of grew up together and she is a
control freak if she does not see it
being implemented the same way that she
would do it she's going to jump in and
she's going to take over but is it
overbearing is it too controlling yes
it's either her way or the highway and
it inhibits anyone to show off their
skills or what they can do or what they
can bring to the restaurant but you have
someone that's down your throat
constantly and really doesn't know what
they're doing they if you were so right
obviously the restaurant wouldn't be
failing or in a situation as it did not
but it's a very valid point you've
employed some talented individuals okay
Porsche
Shelley needs to learn how to delegate
responsibility
you can't be Hands-On all the time it
creates a problem oh my God chili in all
honesty you take somebody out of what
they're supposed to be doing and make
them do something else and that's one
thing you got to realize and that
happens more often I think that you talk
too much and you know too much
that's what makes this so rough the way
be quiet time we're in the way everybody
has been pushed off their position
Dwayne calm down I'm not I wasn't upset
I'm asking you to calm down I want you
to leave good night
honestly hurts the truth hurts
[Music]
just bear with me for two minutes sit
down please okay regardless what is
wrong with you I made one comment what's
become evident is how fragmented we are
but that starts from the top
Chef Shelly have to learn how to listen
everybody tries to communicate with her
and support her but if she's going to be
stubborn and not listen the doors will
close and that would just break my heart
I mean tremendously from now on in
open
honest dialogue got it yes Shelly
Shelly I can't hear you I'm listening no
we're all together
are we going to be open-minded I have
been open-minded as far as I'm concerned
why do you say that this is not a joke
we're in a serious serious position
there's no reason why you cannot be open
and honest because my I'm 72 years old
and I thank God that I've been able to
live this long
and these are the most important things
that I try to project
listen to what this gentleman has to say
I want to move forward I'm here to help
right and the direction is to you
Shelley because there's some valuable
information that we've just listened to
we know you're the boss what you haven't
got right now is successful restaurant
and everyone in this room including me
are here to make that a success but you
have to get out of denial
agreed I agree I can't hear you I agree
thank you
only time will tell whether Shelley has
really understood what the staff was
saying come with me let's go in the
kitchen let's get to work but Chef
Ramsay has already implemented a drastic
change in the kitchen
[Music]
my God oh my God oh my God I called a
friend Kelly quit and he arranged for a
brand new fire and a state of the art
Six Ring burner an amazing convection
oven from South Bend incredible
um a six bonus stole Tyrone
I just can't believe
unbelievable I've had it done especially
for your baking as well
yeah I'm bursting at the seams just I
just can't believe it oh man this is
awesome it's the walk done there's no
way no we can start to move forward
cooking on a Chinese walk
a walk that you cannot cook soul food on
we have a proper system here where's the
worm I am definitely gonna miss my walk
but it's just gonna be an adjustment for
me oh my God I just can't believe this
happy Mary father God I just can't thank
you enough
I'm glad you're happy oh this is just so
wonderful this is truly truly a blessing
Chef Ramsay is he's unbelievable I truly
believe in the power of prayer I prayed
so hard that you would come and that you
were going to turn this restaurant
around I'm just so overwhelmed I thank
you so much
[Music]
thank you
now that the kitchen has functional
equipment okay there's one thing that's
missing here as a structure what what
system are we following here we're going
to work as a team Chef Ramsay appoints a
leader tomorrow night my team yes I want
you cooking you're Expediting yes chef
Randy helped Implement a system to help
this restaurant run very smoothly from
now until forever I'm gonna make
something very very simple with you all
now just a stunning mac and cheese he
also works with the chefs on some new
cooking techniques golden brown take a
spoon and have a little taste Chef
Ramsay has suggestions I'm going to do
my best to be as open as I can
but I just I don't know we are gonna
reopen this session tomorrow night with
a system one voice one leader yes and
work as a team a system don't change it
coming up Shelly I'm coming it's the
relaunch of blackberries
[Music]
will Shelley be able to handle the
changes
and later a surprise ending we have
worked our ass off you have to see to
believe
[Music]
after the implementation of a new system
in the kitchen Chef Ramsay and his team
worked through the night to give the
dining room a much needed makeover
okay good morning
excited to see inside yeah yes let's go
Welcome to the New Black press
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
when I first arrived here there was a
cafeteria the menu on the wall and it
just lost that into the sea now it's a
restaurant gone is the cafeteria you
have a wonderful amazing new restaurant
brand new tables brand new chairs
there's a totally different place
[Music]
yes
I promise you they're not your records I
i's restaurant the artwork
[Music]
will absolutely love it
the soul is back I'm just so excited and
so grateful I'm just overwhelmed Shelly
how'd you feel I feel great
and thank God my middle name's James
right
now that blackberries has an updated
look now for the exciting part the food
Chef Ramsay has created a fresh new soul
food menu to match it what we've done is
taken some of the dishes and modernize
them a little bit give them a bit of a
new twist standing off with a black eyed
pea fritters delicious barbecue pulled
pork sliders wonderful starter entrees
fried chicken and waffles with the honey
butter
I love that a southern meatloaf sandwich
done with mac and cheese and a spicy
glaze like a really nice rich spicy
ketchup
man I love it I love it Shelly looked
like she was embracing the change very
well I'm glad that Chef Ramsey finally
broke through to her is that beautiful
dig in and have a taste
oh my God fried chicken and waffles and
blackberries his menu is great
wow I think I have a wedding combination
here Chef did it food atmosphere we're
ready
oh that's heaven
it's relaunch night at blackberries okay
we're about to open we put a structure
in place and Chef Ramsay has given them
all the tools they need to make this
restaurant a success let's go
[Music]
good afternoon welcome to blackberries
with the restaurant filling up
the Fork Sliders and orders coming in
from the dining room okay order in it's
now up to the newly appointed leader
Chef Mateen to take charge of the
kitchen one jerk Wings one shorty one
chicken with white meat Fried Chicken
white meat six minutes Echo thank you
good off we go here we go oh thank you
let's go with Chef Ramsay's new system
in place and the team working together
Shelley six minutes of sales
thank you dinner service is off to a
smooth start okay here we go
out in the dining room
ERS are thrilled with what they are
receiving I need
a surety
hey Dad you okay the restaurant is
packed wait till you see it you're not
trying to believe it I need an exhale
and a shorty right now I'm on the line a
little bit tonight Shelly Shelly he was
asking for stuff and you're just
ignoring him I'm coming okay all right
love you Dad you okay let's go please
all right Charlie being on the
on a totally disrespectful and a slap in
the face to her kitchen team what she's
saying is I don't give a damn it's my
world and this is the way I'm gonna do
it the rest of you who cares how long
for my oxtail what what
things are going really well at the
beginning because they were being
executed but then I just don't think
Shelley wanted to be there I need an
oxtail and a shorty first
what she's not in control and if she's
not in control she doesn't want to
follow it Shelly yes yes it's like we
just switched off and forgotten why have
we forgotten our systems the most
important thing about a system is
keeping it yes go back to your stations
I am the owner for this business and I'm
just not taking any [ __ ] from anyone
hell no what is this what
coin in it
[Music]
I know honey
yeah so don't do that you're doing
you're going back again
out come here no come here come here
look at me I only ask you don't do it
yes we're going back again we're going
back to old [ __ ] ways don't touch
what he's doing okay you said it's dry
was it dry the corner no it wasn't
[ __ ] dry it wasn't even done thank
you I don't care Chef Ramsay system
works is this Shelley that doesn't want
it to work so when it's sitting on the
side dry now just leave it there
chilling I'm not talking back Shelly now
you walk away bye goodbye goodbye is
gone bye see you later it's relaunch
night at blackberries don't touch what
he's doing and as Chef Ramsay tries to
keep everything on track
[Music]
Shelley goes off the rails goodbye
he's gone and storms out of the kitchen
bye
unbelievable what happened they were
doing so good yeah Shelly started coming
in and picking up bits and just chopping
them I asked to stop it and let my team
do it and she got really funny ever
since then she just switched off so
she's closed down
Shelly is a crybaby she's not willing to
admit that she's wrong
and that's pretty sad with Shelley out
of the kitchen stop everything you're
doing plate this one for me right now
Chef Mateen and the staff try to pull it
together okay and we're gonna stick it
out right now to get the remaining
dishes to the hungry diners
you've got to push it yes chef you
control the kitchen yes I need right now
I need two Fried Green Tomatoes I need
that now working okay nice let's go
maybe they're waiting to take this out
for table one please Dwayne off you go
so we're 50. let's go finally
might be a little slow but it's gonna be
great with Mateen leading the kitchen
and he just had a fries open the window
now shout out of fries good the final
entrees make their way out to the dining
room
are loving the food it's worth the wait
[Music]
he ran so smooth we have the system now
this right here is the first day of
greatness of many more days to come and
I loved it a lot everything was great
thank you
[Music]
with the staff completing a successful
relaunch Chef Ramsay gathers the group
uh okay but there's someone missing
where's uh
Shelly in the office
[Music]
Shelly
can I can I talk to you
please
Shelly
silly there's no point making yourself
look any more stupid Shelly just two
seconds
not gonna argue
coming we
Shelley needs to listen to Chef Ramsay
you just can't close heirs to someone
that's come to help you please
[Music]
if you're outside out of respect for
your staff well then you want them to
walk out on you and you'll have the
restroom oh man I'll clean up tonight
forget about cleaning up tonight what
about the rest of the days
and I'm so ashamed of you that I don't
know what to do
we have worked our ass off
[Music]
done close
down
let's go with Tyrone
[Music]
I don't believe Shea deserves all this
great help she got I mean someone like
me that's been cooking and going to
culinary school would kill for something
like this opportunity you know
it saddens me so much
[Music]
okay
I know it's been a rough night
but on a personal note I just want to
say thank you why because you guys
worked your putt off nobody gave up
there's something personal about soul
food for me
I started a small little documentary
called Kitchen Nightmares seven years
ago and my first ever restaurant was a
Soul Food shack
it's why I started putting back into the
industry and you guys deserve success
you did a fantastic job Chef Ramsey he's
up there with the best Angels I'm just
so delighted and so grateful and we are
going to do our part to make him proud
of us
we definitely will make sure that your
efforts were not in vain thank you
[Music]
Kelly is the world's greatest Chef in
here to teach her and to help her
business but she may throw this all the
whole system out the window with the
whole menu only time can tell
can we have 30 seconds please I think
this is my office are you asking me for
30 seconds at my office yes I am
absolutely not
okay that just sums it up yeah that's
the only thing I haven't changed
[Music]
I really wanted a happy ending tonight
why because this week I've met some
amazing people mother Mary what a
sweetheart and a phenomenal cook my team
that guy has a bright future and he is
packed with passion but the fate and the
future of blackberries rests in the
hands of Shelley and unfortunately
wrestlers do not succeed when they're
run by a dictator
I planted a mouse
is she crazy
[Music]
in the weeks that followed hi nice to
see you customers responded well to the
changes Chef Ramsay made to the menu and
the decor the steak is tender after
witnessing the positive reviews
surprisingly Shelley embraced all that
Chef Ramsay has done for blackberries
I was so skeptical but Chef Ramsay has
opened up a new world for us here at
blackberries I'm ready for change it was
difficult for me to see that at the
beginning but here it is the truth is
the life if you guys enjoy foreign